>> Tucker: A SERIAL BOMBER
IS TERRORIZING THE CITY OF
AUSTIN, TEXAS.
A TRIP WIRE SET OFF A BOMB.
FOURTH BOMBING IN THREE
WEEKS.
TERRY TURCHIE IS DIRECTOR OF
COUNTER TERRORISM.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: FROM WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THESE EXPLOSIONS IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT CONNECTS
THEM, A THEME.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK WE
KNOW OF A THEME THAT
CONNECTS THEM.
RIGHT NOW THE BEST
INFORMATION, TUCKER, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE IS THE
FORENSIC ASPECT OF THEM.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HELP
US AT LEAST IN THESE INITIAL
DAYS TO TRY TO PUT ALL OF
THIS TOGETHER BECAUSE PEOPLE
AT THE LAB, ATF LAB, THE
POLICE LAB, THE FBI'S LAB
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT EVERY LITTLE ASPECT OF
CRIME DEBRIS, OF THINGS
FOUND AT CRIME SCENES AND
EVERYTHING FROM SWITCHES AND
BOMBS TO THE EXPLOSIVE MAIN
CHARGES TO THE WAY THE
CONTAINMENT VESSELS WERE
DESIGNED, ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE A PART OF THE
BOMBER'S SIGNATURE.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO TELL
US, FIRST OF ALL, IF THEY
HAVE EVER SEEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS BEFORE.
EVEN, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU TALK
ABOUT TRIP WIRES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT TRIP
WIRES CONJURES UP IS THE
IDEA OF MAYBE YOU SOMEBODY
FROM THE MILITARY OR MAYBE
SOMEONE WHO WAS PART OF SOME
GURL LA
GUER LA
GUERILA
GUERILLA WARFARE MOVEMENT.
THEY CAN MAKE A GUESS SKILLS
AND TALENTS FROM LOOKING AT
THE WAY THE BOMB WAS
ASSEMBLED AND THEN WE GO
FROM THERE.
YOU JUST CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE, PARTICULARLY
NOW THAT WE HAVE ONLY HAD
AND I SAY ONLY IT'S VERY SAD
AND TRAGIC, BUT THAT'S NOT A
LOT OF BOMBINGS TO BE ABLE
TO TELL A LOT YET, ALTHOUGH
THE LAB CAN TELL A GREAT
DEAL FROM THE FORENSICS.
>> Tucker: SO THERE WAS
EARLY RECKLESS SPECULATION
BY THE PRESS THAT THESE WERE
RACIALLY MOTIVATED WHICH IS
THE LAST THING THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THE
VICTIMS WERE BLACK, WHITE,
HISPANIC, SO THERE IS NO
OBVIOUS RACIAL PATTERN HERE.
AGAIN, THANK HEAVEN.
BUT CAN YOU THINK ARE THERE
OTHER MOTIVES THAT COME
IMMEDIATELY TO MIND?
>> WELL, I'M GLAD YOU ASKED
THAT BECAUSE HERE'S WHAT I
LEARNED FROM UNABOMBER AND
FROM THE OLYMPIC BOMBING,
TUCKER.
EVEN IN LEADING THE TASK
FORCES THERE, WE TRIED TO
STAY AWAY FROM MOTIVE.
NOW, MOTIVE IS IMPORTANT IF
YOU MAY HAVE A NAME.
BUT, WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO
GET ON THE TRAIL TO IDENTIFY
SUBJECT, YOU CAN ABSOLUTELY
FIND YOURSELF IN THE SWAMP
AND THINK BACK A COUPLE
EXAMPLES.
AFTER THE OKLAHOMA CITY
BOMBING.
ALL OF THE UPROAR AND THE
CRYING ABOUT MIDDLE EASTERN
ARABS, QUOTE, BEING INVOLVED
IN THAT, THAT TURNED OUT TO
OBVIOUSLY BE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
THINK ABOUT ANTHRAX, IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE 9/11
ATTACKS AND THEN THE ANTHRAX
ATTACKS WHICH WERE JUST
LITERALLY WEEKS LATER, THERE
WAS THIS TREMENDOUS PUSH TO
LITERALLY BLAME THAT ON
SADDAM HUSSEIN IN IRAQ.
IN FACT, CAN I TELL YOU
STRAIGHT OUT THAT THE FBI AT
THAT POINT IN TIME WAS
INVOLVED IN CONFRONTATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO SLOW THAT
THINKING DOWN.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER THAT.
>> EVEN THEN EARLY ON.
>> Tucker: I REMEMBER BILL
KRISTOL GETTING OUT THERE
SAND SAYING WE THINK SADDAM
DID THIS AS PRETEXT FOR A
WAR IN IRAQ.
OF COURSE IT WAS ALL LYING
AND PROPAGANDA AS USUAL.
AGAIN, THESE ARE NOT SENT,
THESE WERE PLACED OUTSIDE
HOMES?
THAT SEEMS ODD TO ME.
>> IT IS ODD.
AND HERE'S WHAT IT SUGGESTS.
WHEN YOU GO INTO A
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND YOU WALK UP ON
SOMEBODY'S PORCH AND YOU
PLACE A PACKAGE, OR YOU GO
OUT INTO ANOTHER RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YOU TAKE
THE TIME THAT'S REQUIRED TO
PLACE AND THEN SET AND
PREPARE A TRIP WIRE BOMB TO
GO OFF, YOU'RE REALLY
PROBABLY FAMILIAR OR AT
LEAST AT THE VERY LEAST FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE IN THAT
KIND OF SURROUNDING.
GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE.
TWO BOMBINGS IN 1982 AND
1985 AT COREY HALL AT UC
BERKELEY UNIBOMB.